for our daily cancellation today we
consult Fortune Magazine which reports
that genz according to research may be
psychologically scarred by high
inflation even worse says this research
the damage may be permanent reading on
Jen's early careers uh have been stifled
by a number of challenges from a once-
in a generation pandemic and a war on
European soil to spiraling living costs
and recession fears that have led to
widespread layoffs but according to new
research the economic backdrop in which
young people are entering the workforce
could have a much deeper impact on gen Z
than a squeeze on their Lifestyles Dio
em ainu Sawa founder of London's AWA
business school and a former lecture at
Cambridge University's judge business
school told vun on Monday that the
ongoing battle with uh inflation would
have had a serious impact on the mindset
of gen Z workers those under a uh those
aged 26 and under gen ZZ will be left
with psychological scars from persistent
inflation due to increased uncertainty
and anxiety he cautioned a society where
the young have little to know hope for
the future is not a sustainable one not
only will gen Z be left with
psychological scars Society at large
will also feel the impact of those scars
so young people are not just dealing
with aqi economy they are experiencing
permanent psychological damage a
terminal loss of Hope and a profound
sense of unease and anxiety now of
course we hear a lot about the anxiety
of gen Z these days in fact uh the hill
just reported this month that gen Z is
the most anxious generation in history
and before gen Z we were told that
Millennials were the most anxious in
history now apparently we have been
unseated we've been dethroned by gen Z
reading now from that report a new
report from data management firm Harmony
Healthcare it shows that 61% of genz
have a medically diagnosed anxiety
condition the report includes a survey
of about a thousand geners or adults
aged uh 18 to 26 who struggle with
anxiety about their uh anxious thoughts
and while experiencing anxiety is
nothing new for jenz uh more than half
of survey respondents 54% said their
anxiety has been worse this year and out
of those those with anxiety 43% said
they experience a panic attack at least
once a month if not more frequently the
most common cause of their anxiety the
future almost uh most of those surveyed
have said the future was the was the
biggest worry while 45% said it was
finances almost one in three jier
surveyed with anxiety said they used
medication to help them manage the
symptoms okay 61% have been medically
diagnosed with anxiety disorder so think
about that for a second that's it that's
a staggering number
61% that is how anxious these young
people are and and many of them are
having panic attacks once a
month I don't even know what a panic
attack is I I but but they're they're
having them all the
time that's how anxious they are it's
how difficult their lives are how
terrible the situation that they find
themselves in is at least that's what
we're supposed to believe anyway and
listen there is no denying that the
economy is in rough shape right
inflation is a major problem the
American dream is harder to attain for
young people today than it was for
Boomers when they were this age my
parents generation they were able to
trade like two pineapples and a bag of
flour for a single family home with a
half acre of land now I may be slightly
exaggerating but the point is that a
certain lifestyle was much easier to
establish and maintain only a few
decades ago there's no denying
that and Beyond the economy it's also
true that our culture is in in bad shape
the situation abroad is even more
volatile and so on so are challenges
there are difficult challenges nobody
can pretend
otherwise that said there is a real
tendency to grossly exaggerate the
difficulties that we face today and it's
not just gen Z in fact I recently saw a
viral meme that was doing the the uh the
rounds on Twitter and it has this whole
woe is me stick except for Millennials
and the meme shows Matthew mccon puffing
on a cigarette with a Shell Shocked look
on his face along with the caption
Millennials living through Y2K 9911 a
plague to economic recessions and a
possible World War III before they turn
40 now it's true that some of those
things were
hard on the other hand if you're
including Y2K on your list of
generational traumas then it's clear
that you're really trying to pad the
stats because Y2K is famous for being an
occasion where literally nothing
happened at all as for the rest of it uh
you know some of it 9/11 especially also
the government response to co uh qualify
as legitimate catastrophic but if you
take a couple of steps back you can see
that we have had it relatively Easy by
comparison so consider for example that
somebody born in 1910 would have before
retirement lived through World War I
World War II the Great Depression the
Spanish Flu the Cold War the Korean War
the Vietnam War and a presidential
assassination that's only a partial list
somebody born a century before that
would have experienced two Wars or more
like uh 20 Wars if you count all the
Indian Wars individually before the
Civil War in which 2 and a half% of the
country's population died two and a
half% which is the equivalent of around
8 million American American casualties
today so imagine like uh the entire
population of of Virginia dying a
horrible death in the span of four years
and you get an idea of the
devastation so um my point is is not to
downplay our struggles today it's to put
them into perspective and to make the
point that every generation of human
beings who've ever lived have faced
turmoil and tragedy this is the price of
admission into the human species it's a
condition of existing on the planet and
in fact it Remains the case that most
generations of humans perhaps only with
the exception of the Baby Boomers who
had it really easy but everybody else
you know they they have had by any
objective measure a significantly more
difficult time than us certainly they
have a beat when it comes to economic
hardship War
disease I mean you should thank God
every day that you didn't happen to be
born in France in the year 1340 a few
years before the black death would
proceed to wipe 200 million people off
the face of the planet I mean imagine
watching as everyone around you breaks
out in festering oozing boils before
they eventually die in puddles of their
own vomit and blood only to soon suffer
the same fate
yourself and then you'll get a pretty
good idea of of why you are in many many
ways incredibly blessed to have been
born at a time when a bad cold is the
only quote plague you've ever
experienced our friends at genus cell
have launched a new product called
genell 3 which works fast on your under
eye bags and puffiness genu cell 3 is
smoother more luxurious and it uses
advanced technology to deliver complex
vitamins and minerals directly to your
face for instant hydration it's like
Gatorade for your skin this new gen cell
technology keeps your skin looking young
and healthy for years to come J cell
fall Classics package also includes a
jawline treatment for more firm uh neck
and jawlines it also includes genu
cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum go to jys cell.com
Walt for extra discounts on this amazing
fall package get your skin ready for the
cold and dry weather if you don't look
and feel your absolute best you'll get
your money back no questions asked
that's jus.com
walshy now again the fact that hundreds
of generations of humans have had lives
that were something like a thousand
times more difficult and arduous and
brutal than ours that doesn't make our
own sufferings illegitimate it just
means that that we should have
perspective and part of having
perspective is realizing that no matter
how hard you think you have it you
essentially live like a Roman Emperor
compared to almost everyone who's ever
existed on the planet and even compared
to most of the people who currently
exist on the
planet so then we have to
ask why is Gen Z so especially
traumatized and psychologically scarred
and anxiety-ridden
sure rent is too high mortgages are too
high groceries are too expensive but
does that justify over half of an entire
generation being diagnosed with an
anxiety condition does that does that
justify monthly panic
attacks does that justify uh being
dependent on psychiatric medicine to
function like it's not that bad okay
it's just
not now those people in the past to
endured hardship that gen Z can't even
begin to Fathom they didn't need anxiety
medication they had never heard of panic
attacks either like that didn't exist
panic attacks are new that's that didn't
happen in the 1800s nobody was talking
about panic attacks so so what's the
problem is it that people today are just
simply weak is it as simple as
that well yeah pretty much I mean it's
as simple as that that's actually what's
happening as a group collectively we
certainly do not experience more suffer
suffering or more hardship than humans
of the past but we are less able to deal
with suffering and hardship the cross
that we carry is smaller it's lighter
but our shoulders are not as Broad and
our backs are not as strong and there
are many reasons for this we live in
relative comfort and luxury which has
made us soft we also again as a culture
are more secular more nihilistic more
materialistic and this has caused a kind
of spiritual atrophy it has made us
psychologically
brittle but um and things like dealing
with the reality of death is I think
much more difficult for us because we
are secular materialistic nihilistic uh
you know we believe that we're going to
die and and and fade into non-existence
which I think makes death far more
terrifying uh anyway so there's a lot
going on but underlying all of that is
the uniquely modern assumption that life
is supposed to be essentially pain-free
so we think that we are entitled to
comfort that we have the right to avoid
suffering and hardship and those are
assumptions that our ancestors would
have never made our ancestors
encountered death and pain and suffering
and they said well this is what life is
it's not that they weren't sad about it
okay they were sad they were distraught
the family member dies something
terrible happens but they said this is
what life is life is suffering we
encounter that sort of thing much less
of it and we say no it's not supposed to
be this way it's not fair it's not fair
this is not how life is supposed to
be you you see all these videos of gen Z
people that are like in tears because
they have to work 9 to5 now in tears
about it it's not supposed to be this
way this is not how life is supposed to
be no one in history thought that way
everyone in history well of course you
have to work what else what else are you
going to do in life it's life what do
you mean it's it's not not fair not fair
compared to
what most of the anxiety and Trauma and
psychological scarring comes not from
from the suffering but really from this
refusal to suffer this insistence that
life owes us something else something
better which in fact when in fact it
owes us
nothing now I'm not offering any kind of
great Insight here but it's somehow an
Insight that has never occurred to a
shockingly large number of people in
modern culture they have lived their
whole lives without anyone responding to
one of their complaints by saying yeah
that's life get over it stop crying you
I mean that is a message we should
all probably here once a day and if
you're having a panic attack because you
know of inflation like you the best
thing you could hear from someone is get
it together what the hell is wrong with
you like you need to be able to function
this is
embarrassing once a day we should
probably all hear something like that
and if not once a day then at least once
in our lives but plenty of young people
have never heard that response from
anyone every time they whine about
something it's so hard all they ever
hear is yeah it is so hard it's so
difficult yeah tell me more about how
you
feel what they really need they need
their feelings to be dismissed at least
every once in a while keeps you
humble and now they're crippled by paper
cuts and they're psychologically scarred
by minor
inconveniences and this all means that
eventually and likely soon we will
actually experience the agonies of our
ancestors as the saying goes weak men
create hard times and that is the point
in the historical cycle that we have
reached and it is for that reason that
these weak men are today cancelled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast